In this lesson, we're going to go ahead and take a look at Final Pixel and ICBFX workflows
when it comes to ray tracing.
This is a bit of a review from previous classes, but let's go ahead and get started.
So here are a few things to keep in mind when working with ray tracing.
One, you want to keep the ray tracing environment small.
So you only use ray tracing in a small region for performance costs.
And the reason why you do that is mainly because of the photon bounces that go around, they
can get costly if your scene is quite huge.
And you will see your frame rates drop.
It can be mixed with baking as needed so you could bake in the background and then do ray
tracing in a small contained area in your post-process volume.
With ray tracing, keeping in mind your polycount is very key.
You want to make sure you avoid having really tiny details like if you have a lot of foliage
and a lot of plants, it doesn't mean you can't do it.
It's just the photons bouncing back from those cards going back to the camera can get expensive
as things get heavier.
So you might want to put some maybe some alpha cards in the background to maybe fake some
of those trees in the distance and so forth.
Keep textures simple and roughness wise because that also can bring things to a crawl because
then you're getting the photons trying to determine the material ID and material information
on those objects.
The higher the rough, the more complicated that's going to be for ray tracing to calculate
that and get it back to the camera so that it has a fair representation of that object.
So also you want to keep your, when you do use your textures, you can use virtual texturing.
Your texture overhead, just make sure the priority areas are their main concern or the main thing
so that your textures aren't really high everywhere.
Material nodes, you can use a switch replacing or manual based kind of like a static switch
parameter.
This is in previous classes I talked about how can you use either or when it comes to
ray tracing.
This is more per shot.
This is one that manages things as you're working in your workflow.
Overall, as your camera moves around in your environment, avoid physical lights intersecting
into geo.
That's really important because as you do that noise can be persistent.
Say I got a simple light in my scene, it's a rec light and I'm pushing it through a wall,
accidentally maybe it's clipping, you're going to see some noise show up on those materials
if you're not careful.
Use reflection probes and CVARS to manage hybrid output for best performances.
So you can run that and make it so that Unreal is going to lean on those for your shinier
objects and reflective transparent surfaces.
Use CVARS for better performance overall, also in your movie RenderCube.
So we go over that in our rendering classes, but these are things to keep in mind when
working with ray tracing because ray tracing overall can be expensive.
Let's go and take a peek a little bit in Unreal and you can kind of see what I'm talking about.
So in my scene here, this does have ray tracing on, but I'm using two different post process
volumes to demonstrate some blood information from a previous class.
We're going to pull in a new post process volume and we're going to contain it within
the area of our metal objects here.
So pull this guy in into my scene, let me go and increase his size a bit.
So again, you want to handle the ray tracing for that particular region in a very dialed
down and controlled set.
Now also photons bouncing around in an interior can get a bit more expensive.
Ray tracing in an interior can be a bit more expensive versus outdoors.
Outdoors things are a lot easier to calculate, but when you have multiple things in an enclosed
area, you're getting some photons bouncing back faster back to the camera and you do
need to manage things accordingly.
So just be careful how many items you have in there and your material complexity if you
choose to go that route.
So in here, I'm going to activate ray tracing in my post process volume in my GI settings
here.
Let me close a few things we don't need.
So let's go to global illumination.
Let's set this to ray tracing.
You can see that it's active there.
In my ray tracing, I'm going to set this to, you can even mix these if you want to do,
that's Lumen right there for reflections.
We're going to set that to ray tracing in this particular case.
And I'm going to show you what I mean.
So we can run this CVAR right here called ray tracing dot reflection, reflection captures.
Right now it says zero, but if you want to lean on things and do more of a hybrid set,
I can put a one in here and enter.
And it's going to allow me to have a bit of a fallback.
You will see a bunch of noise in here.
You see that.
And we can actually adjust the roughness in here and it being ray tracing.
We're going to probably need to.
We can also set in hybrid in here in our scene.
And you'll see reflection ray tracing hybrid.
And we can also set that to one.
I'll hit one here and hit enter.
And you're going to see an active, there you go.
You see a quick changer.
So that hybrid is also referencing what we put in before, which was a reflection captures.
So I put my reflection capture here.
We can set that to zero.
What that does is sets a fallback for some of our reflectivity in our materials here.
And it allows you to get a better result.
Now it works a bit better when it comes to translucency.
I'm really just using it in my metal aspects here.
But again, I'm using it in a contained area and that hybrid is using some of those reflection
captures as a reference, as you saw that shift as I brought it into my scene.
So let's turn a few other things on to actually see some better results.
So on ray tracing, I'm going to turn on my max bounces.
And I'm going to set this to simple final gather.
You'll see that shift there for a second here.
Final gather can bring a bit of noise.
So we may even want to switch this to brute force.
This will give us better results and we can set these numbers a bit higher.
Making this eight and if your computer supports it, samples for pixel can be 16 also.
This could also be four in our case.
And then we can set this to six to eight as a starter point.
Then underneath our reflectivity here, we have ray tracing.
So we can actually manage our ray tracing here.
Things have slowed down a little bit here because we do have a lot of reflective surfaces.
I'll even notice my particles are slowing down just a bit there.
I can control my max roughness if I wanted to samples for pixel shadows.
We have hard shadows.
I can set those to area shadows to be a bit better.
And then I can lower my roughness if I wanted to.
You can see you can get rid of some of the noise that may be occurring or you can increase
it back to where it was.
And you will see the noise persist if you are not careful.
So let's set that back to default for a second there.
And again, as we move in our scene, we can see some of the results of our work.
So again, using brute force is ideal in your post process volume.
And you can start low and then go high if you need to.
brute force and final gather.
Again, there's always going to be a bit of a noise and either one, but brute force is
going to give you less.
You can also use stat D3D12RAT and GPU stats to track performance for ray tracing global
illumination to work with a skylight enabled.
The experimental console variable ray tracing global illumination evaluate sky can be turned
on.
This actually works pretty well most of the time to make sure that the sky is being evaluated
accordingly.
So again, using that reflection captures hybrid CVAR and sorting materials, which can increase
things performance wise.
So you can use all three of these to actually help out.
Now here's some ideal CVARs for final renders to be placed in the render queue.
So these definitely can help out.
Now, do you need all these not necessarily all at one time experiment with them first?
Don't plug all these in in your movie render queue before you know whether you really do
need them.
So just be very deterministic.
It's like, you know, you can say, Hey, this is my depth of field quality.
Not that good.
Then I'll use this ice cream percentage.
I need to increase that so make things look a little better.
Motion blur quality, but all that looks, it needs, it looks great the way it is.
I don't need to change it.
So you have to be very deterministic through here.
You can also change your speaking of shadow quality on this one.
You can also change your ray tracing shadow quality within the light itself.
But a lot of times you don't necessarily need that or the eyes not even going to pick it
up.
It does change it ever so slightly the quality wise of your shadow.
But for the most part, most of those shadows should work just fine in the default setting.
They do cost GPU wise if you were to mess with those.
Now just for shocking purposes, I kept in this part of the lecture, what's talks about
if you wanted to use ray tracing and to turn it on and off as you're using GPU light mass.
And that's fine.
You just got to make sure you run that CVAR.
I gave you earlier, what turns off all ray tracing effects in your scene.
Once you've, once you've rendered things in GPU light mass, now you can turn ray tracing
on and off if you need to.
And you'll have to dump some of your baked information back and forth.
It's a little bit of a hassle.
And this is why Lumen's a little bit better.
But these workflows are there if for some reason you need to use them.
That's it with this lecture.
Here's a link here where you can dive in a bit deeper on these subjects.
Thanks again.
And in the next lecture, we're going to go and take a look at optimizing fog effects.